This world is not yet ready
for all that you will do
your time will come diana
and everything will be different
citizens of the world i'm here to change your life
anything you want
anything you dream of you can have it
like you saw a ghost
diana lucky you it's like now one day has passed
i don't want to be like anyone
i want to be an apex predator
you've always had everything while
people like me have had nothing
well now it's my turn
get used to it
i've never been one for rules
the answer is always more
the way i fly they will never find us i forgot to
tell you what radar will they will they shoot at
us barbara what did you do
you know i'm not so keen on this one i figure
uh you are but you know what i'm ready to go i
think we can do better parachute pants
yeah um does everybody parachute now
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie big surprise
this is going to be my new wonder woman 1984
trailer video they just announced what's going on
with the release and you will barely believe that
it is coming to hbo max so i'll explain what's
going on because it's a bit of a complicated
release but they're trying to keep it as simple
as possible but if you've been waiting for new
movies to finally start coming out big movies your
prayers have finally been answered so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos of course i'll be doing videos
for this movie thankfully it's finally coming out
and we'll do a giveaway for hbo max subscriptions
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know what you want them to do with wonder
woman after wonder woman 1984. patty jenkins has
explained some of her plans for the wonder woman
3 movie after wonder woman 1984 but i'll explain
that later in the video the biggest breaking news
just in the last hour is that literally they
just announced obviously in this trailer that
they're going to release the movie christmas day
at the same time as they release it theatrically
so what's happening is is some theaters around
the world will still be open but a lot of places
are heading into another lockdown period so even
if you wanted to go to a theater you still can't
do that and originally they delayed the movie so
many times everybody pressed f in the chat for new
mutants in wonder woman their official release
date had moved to christmas day but that was
on the assumption that the virus would be under
control and people would be able to go to theaters
theaters would actually be allowed to be opened
that all changed in the last couple of weeks so a
lot more movies have been delayed since then but
because warner brothers is desperately thirsty
for hbo max subscriptions they want to do
everything they can to get people to pay for it
and this is probably the most expensive but the
best possible ad that they can do for that service
how do you get people to subscribe and pay for
your service you release big content that they
want and we all just want to see some new content
some new movies some new tv series so they don't
want to completely throw the theatrical release
business under the bus they still want to release
big movies in theaters and patty jenkins is
hardcore about people going to see this in a
movie theater but this is them acknowledging that
it's going to be a long time before that happens
so the extra good news though is that you won't
have to pay any extra money on top of your hbo max
subscription service if you didn't see that little
tag at the end of the trailer no extra cost to hbo
max subscribers and if you don't get hbo max in
the country where you live they'll probably be
releasing it in theaters where you live or video
on demand in some alternate route so there will
be some way for you to see the movie i wouldn't
worry too much about that this is patty jenkins
official statement because what happened is warner
brothers accidentally leaked this information out
they posted a trailer before they meant to people
caught it then this card with all the information
about the christmas release date leaked out in
hbo max so finally they're like okay we'll say
something about this officially i'm just going
to read from patty jenkins statement here and gal
gadot also retweeted her statement she says it's
time we've all waited a long time for this one to
come i can't tell you how excited i am for all of
you to see this movie it wasn't an easy decision
and we never thought we'd have to hold on to the
release for such a long time but cove had rocked
all of our worlds we feel the movie has never been
so relevant and we hope that it'll bring some joy
hope and love to your hearts wonder woman 1984 is
a special one for me and i can only hope it'll be
as special to you too we put our hearts and souls
into it so you can watch it in theaters they're
doing an amazing job keeping it safe and you can
watch it on hbo max from your homes sending you
my love please keep safe and wear a mask happy
holidays to all of us let the light shine in
so that explains it all if there are theaters
near you that are open you can go see it in a
theater christmas day but if they're close you
can watch it on hbo max if your subscriber at no
extra cost above the subscription fee the hope is
is that with this move it'll also pressure disney
to do the same thing with disney plus because
if you remember earlier this year they tried to
release mulan through their special service they
called it disney premier access but you had to
pay a bunch of extra money on top of your disney
plus subscription fee to get it they are releasing
their pixar soul movie christmas day so it'll be
competing with wonder woman 1984 on disney plus
for no extra charge so they're already kind of
learning uc but people are now asking will they
do the same thing with the black widow movie and
put it on disney plus and in theaters at the same
time right now that's scheduled for release in may
so i think that they're hoping that the situation
with the virus will be better by then and more
theaters will be open so it won't be as big of an
issue right now without more information and
without knowing exactly what the situation is
next year they'll probably try to still release it
in theaters and then within a couple weeks of that
then drop it on disney plus i've already talked a
lot about what's going on during the wonder woman
1984 movie because there have been so many
trailers because they've delayed the movie
so many times everybody posts all your new mutants
memes we're also going to see wonder woman during
the justice league snyder cup with a bunch of new
footage obviously there's been a couple trailers
for that i just did a brand new justice league
snyder cut trailer yesterday because it was the
anniversary of the justice league release so zack
snyder did this big commentary talking about all
the brand new stuff that he's putting in it there
is a lot of brand new wonder woman and gal gadot
was actually filming the additional photography
with zack snyder so she has some new scenes that
weren't in the previous version of the movie that
he was working on he said that was only about an
extra five minutes but all total there's about
two and a half hours of brand new footage in the
justice league snyder cut total the actual total
run time will be over four hours and even though
he wasn't super clear about it he talked about the
snyder cut as being six parts with an epilogue but
the way that they talked about it earlier is
they're going to release it in four parts and
each part will be one hour long so either we're
going to get four separate episodes of the justice
league snyder cut next year on hbo max or we're
going to get six episodes that are a little bit
shorter with an epilogue they'll figure that out
in the next couple of months but the other big
stuff that's happening right now is they just
announced a wonder woman tv series is happening
with a new version of wonder girl that they just
introduced in the comics if you don't know who
that is her name is yara flor she's the daughter
of an amazon in the brazilian river god but it
sounds like that tv series won't premiere till
2022 it'll be set in the arrowverse and on the cw
so just set your expectations based on what
the other cw shows are like most of the new
big budget dc shows are actually going to hbo max
and they'll be a little bit different different
creative teams and a lot of the directors
that do the movies will be involved with those
like right now as we speak james gunn is in the
middle of filming his suicide squad hbo series
with john cena's peacemaker character those hbo dc
series will directly cross over with the movies a
lot of them star actors that also appear in the
dc movies is the exact same thing that disney
is doing with the marvel disney plus avengers
spin-off series like we have the Wandavision
episodes coming at the beginning of january same
exact thing you have elizabeth olsen you have paul
bettany reprising their characters doing a story
that will influence future marvel phase 4 movies
most of the upcoming dc movie actors like you
have jason momoa's aquaman character wanting to
cross over with wonder woman in aquaman
2 even the rock said in the black adam
trailer from dc fandom that he was putting the
justice league on blast and named wonder woman
so it sounds like he also plans on crossing
over with wonder woman in future movies too
probably not the black adam movie just because
they have to completely explain who the character
is do his origin story and then explain who the
justice society is then i think after that is when
you'll start seeing him cross over with bigger
justice league characters i know everybody wants
to see superman versus black adam it sounds
like the rock is really pulling for that too
so don't be surprised if you also hear about a lot
of wonder woman stuff happening through this hbo
max series that are going to be happening the
next couple of years in terms of wonder woman
3 patty jenkins has just said that it's going
to be set during present day contemporary so
it just increases the likelihood that you'll
see other justice league characters crossing
over into that i've got a couple new mandalorian
season two videos that i'm working on right now my
new mandalorian season 2 episode 4 video will post
friday just like normal and then i have a new darksaber
and Bo Katan video that should post tomorrow
morning as well as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those videos
when i post them while you wait for everything
click here for that brand new batman trailer and
click here for my video on the mandalorian season
2 ahsoka scene thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!